sometimes people are gripped by the
thought that well but hang on this stuff
about caring about future people people
who haven't even been born yet doesn't
make sense because those future people
don't exist it doesn't make sense to
care about people who don't exist I
think this is just a confusing way of
using the word exist it might be helpful
to think of time on an analogy with
space you can picture the universe as a
four-dimensional block there are the
familiar three dimensions the three
dimensions of space time is just the
fourth dimension so when we're talking
about a person who will exist in a
thousand years time you can rephrase
that as thinking about a person who does
exist in this four-dimensional block
just located somewhere different from us
so on that way of thinking talking about
the morality of affecting for our future
people is a very similar set of issues
to talking about the morality of
affecting people who are far away from
us in
space